[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY WEGST: Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
Everybody can hear me OK?
All right, excellent.
Thank you, Michelle,
and I thank you,
[INAUDIBLE] for making
this all come together.
It's been a long journey,
but we finally made it.
Excellent.
Thank you all for
coming this afternoon.
As she mentioned, I'm a
photographer, cinematographer,
who currently specialize
in animal conservation,
wildlife conservation.
I've been doing animal
films for a long time,
but only in the last
three or four years,
have I've been focused
solely on conservation.
Today, I'd like to give
you a presentation I
call the "Struggle of Beauty."
It's a series of
about 40 photographs
that I've spent the
last, say, three or four
years shooting mostly in
Tanzania, Uganda, and Kenya.
There's a couple other
outliers, but mostly
those three countries.
And I've focused
on these countries,
because of an
organization that I
work with in San
Francisco called Wild Aid.
What we do is we work to
reduce the illegal demand
for trafficked wildlife parts.
So elephant ivory, rhino
horn, shark fin soup,
pangolins, you name it,
sea turtles, tigers,
all kinds of animals
that are bought and sold
for mostly bones or skin
or things like that.
In my work in Africa
with Wild Aid,
we do local campaigns in these
countries, Uganda, Tanzania,
Kenya, and now we're
starting Zimbabwe
and Mozambique and Gabon,
where I'll be next week.
And we encourage people there
in Africa on the supply side,
sadly, to take a broader
interest in their wildlife
and in their natural resources
that they have right there
in front of them.
Surprisingly, a lot
of people in Africa
who live next to, for instance,
Amboseli National Park,
this photo here, have never
seen an elephant in real life
or a lion or a rhino.
And so we encourage
these people--
we have a campaign in Africa
called Poaching Steals From Us
All.
And what we try
to do is encourage
people to recognize the
wealth of their own backyard.
The other part of
our work is in Asia,
where the demand side
mostly is, and there,
we carry out large
media campaigns, focused
on changing cultural
attitudes, raising awareness,
those kind of things,
that buying these products
is really not such a great idea.
So with that, we'll get started.
Just to begin with, this is
a lovely herd of elephants
in Amboseli National Park.
You can see Mount
Kilimanjaro sort of shrouded
in the background there.
Has anybody been to Kenya
and seen a good view
of Mount Kilimanjaro?
It's a rare day when you get
to see a nice view of Mount
Kilimanjaro.
This is an elephant
in Serengeti.
Who's been to Africa?
Wow.
That's great.
That's awesome.
And just shout out
what countries?
South Africa, Kenya, Tanzania.
That's awesome.
Rwanda.
Wow, excellent.
And most of those have been
vacations, safari vacations,
things like that?
Has anybody gone for like other
kinds of work or anything?
Excellent.
Well, part of the point of this
exhibition or this presentation
is to peel back the curtain a
little bit on what most of us
normally see when
we go to Africa.
Normally, when we book
a trip to Africa, say,
South Africa or
Kenya or Tanzania,
we go, we get off the plane,
we're met at the airport.
We have a wonderful
safari driver.
We stay in beautiful lodges.
We eat great food,
get up in the morning,
take pictures of
beautiful animals all day,
come home, have a drink,
look at our photos,
Facetime our friends, and
start all over the next day.
And that's a
wonderful experience.
And it can really
give you a vision
of the world that's really
hard to get anywhere else.
And Africa has that
sort of majesty
and that sort of
magic that sucks you
in when you're on safari,
that first elephant you see
in the morning, that
first lion that you see
is just like, whoa, there
is a lion six feet away.
I mean, that's an amazing thing.
But sadly,
unfortunately, there's
a lot of issues
in Africa that we
don't see when we're on safari.
There's a lot of problems that
are just sort of over the hill
or around the corner
or maybe tucked away
in a little metal shed
somewhere that we drive
by on the way to our lodge.
And part of the point
of this presentation
is to peel that curtain back a
little bit and talk about some
of those issues that are a
daily occurrence in Africa.
And a lot of those
issues, there are
a ton of NGOs trying
to help solve,
but the reason I'm excited
to be here at Google today
is that there's so many
great minds at Google
that I think a little
bit of thought here,
I think we could
come up with a lot
of other innovative solutions
on some of these problems.
Some of them are
super easy problems.
They look super easy.
How to keep elephants away
from crops, for instance,
how to keep lions
away from livestock.
There's all sorts of people
trying all sorts of things.
Other problems or more sort of
endemic and economic and larger
scale problems.
But at any rate, that's why
I'm here today as sort of--
to give you a little taste
of all of that stuff.
Obviously, one of the
biggest problems in Africa
today is elephant ivory.
Elephant ivory is still
a widely traded product.
An elephant is killed on
the continent of Africa
roughly every 15 minutes,
and those are always
killed for ivory.
And the sad thing
is, it doesn't matter
how big or old or
young the elephant
is, if there's any ivory
at all, it will be taken.
The good news is in
partnership, Wild Aid
has sort of led
the fight on this,
China has in the last year
banned the sale of ivory.
Hong Kong has banned
the sale of ivory.
Taiwan recently banned
Singapore is about to
ban the sale of ivory.
So there is progress being made.
The price of ivory
is dropping per kilo,
but it's still an expensive
product that people buy.
Japan, if you didn't know,
Japan is the last legal market
for ivory left on the planet.
And we're working hard
to shut that one down.
An animal a lot of
people love, zebras.
I'm sure you all saw zebras
when you were in Africa.
I hope you did, anyway.
They're everywhere.
Zebras are doing well in Africa.
But there are three
subspecies of zebra
that number less-- well, two
of them number less than 800,
and one numbers less than 4,000.
The main zebra is about
200,000 left on the continent.
They're wonderful animals,
but the problem with zebras
is they're running
into a lack of habitat.
As ranching expands,
zebras are now
cohabiting with cows and
sheep and all sorts of things.
And so when you
drive through Africa,
you'll see a lot of zebras
outside the conservancy areas,
hanging out with cows
and all kinds of stuff.
But zebras are a--
who love zebras?
Everybody loves zebras, right?
How many stripes
does a zebra have?
One.
Think about it
just for a minute.
Rhinos, unfortunately rhinos is
another big problem in Africa.
Rhino poaching for the horn.
The horn is worth more by
weight than diamonds, gold,
and cocaine.
Currently, the
price of rhino horn
is somewhere around
$15,000 to $20,000 a kilo.
At its height, it
was $60,000 a kilo.
So the good news is the price
of rhino horn is falling.
But the bad news is
about three rhinos a day
across the African
continent are poached
for rhino horn, three a day.
There's only about 25,000
rhinos left in the wild.
So you do the math.
In the last few years,
something like 6,000 rhinos
have been poached.
So if the current
trend is not reversed,
rhinos could be extinct in the
wild in about 20 years, which
is a sad thing.
The rhino poaching
peaked in the '70s,
and then went down in
the '80s, and early '90s.
And then beginning in the 2000s,
a new market opened in Vietnam
for rhino horn, and they were
claiming that it cured cancer,
that it was an
aphrodisiac, that it
did all these wonderful,
magical things.
Rhino horn, for
your information,
is made of the same thing
as your fingernail, keratin.
So if you really
want rhino horn,
just bite on your
fingernail or your toenail.
There's more of it there.
So what we try to do
is we try to discourage
sales of rhino horn in Asia,
which is a difficult thing
to do.
There's a lot of solutions
people have proposed.
Some conservancies
shave off the horn.
poison the horn.
But this involves a
very expensive process
of tranquilizing the animal
with a vet, bringing it in,
and even with a horn
cut off a rhino,
poachers will still kill the
rhino for the stump of horn,
it's worth that much money.
This rhino is named Najin.
She is one of two
remaining Northern White
Rhinos left on the planet.
She and her pen mate, out of
the photo, are the only two
of this species
left on the planet.
The male died earlier this year.
You may have read about it.
His name was Sudan.
I have a picture
of him coming up.
She is too old to breed,
and so is her friend.
They are kept under lock and
key, 24 hour a day armed guard.
Most conservancies
in Africa that
have rhino populations
in Northern Africa--
just as an aside,
my work, today I'm
going to talk about sort
of Central Eastern Africa.
I'm not going to really mention
South Africa or Botswana or any
of those other places.
The experience here
is in central Africa.
But these problems are
all across the continent.
The problem with having
rhinos on your conservancy,
it's very expensive.
You have to have 24
hour a day armed guards.
So rhino conservation
is a pricey thing,
but it's important.
You guys all saw rhinos
when you were in Africa?
Pretty amazing animals.
Gorillas.
Who's been gorilla trekking?
Yay!
One person.
Gorilla trekking, if there's
one thing you do in Africa,
if you go back to Africa, and
there's one thing you do, this.
Go see a gorilla.
It's a lot of work.
It's a lot of money.
Take some time.
Take some effort.
But it is the most magical thing
you will ever do in your life,
and I guarantee you.
This guy was about six feet
away when I took this photo.
This was in Uganda in
the Bwindi Impenetrable
Forest, which isn't
so impenetrable,
because I got there.
There are about 950
mountain gorillas,
highland mountain
gorillas left in the world
in the sort of corner of
Congo, Rwanda, and Uganda,
in that little area.
They're squeezed in there in
three different national parks.
And gorillas face a
lot of challenges,
habitat loss, deforestation.
They're occasionally
killed for bushmeat
and occasionally killed just
for sport, which thank God,
not a lot happens.
But occasionally, they are.
These are not the kind of
gorillas you'll see in a zoo.
The gorillas in a zoo
are lowland gorillas.
Mountain highland gorillas
don't do well in captivity.
That's why you'll never
see them in a zoo.
But when you see
them in the wild,
this guy was-- like I
said, he's a young male,
I think a male, young male.
He was about six feet away.
When you trek with
gorillas, they
allow you to have an
hour with the gorilla.
So basically, I was just
sitting on the forest floor.
And right before I shot this
photo, the large silverback,
the large male of the group,
who's maybe 400 pounds,
he was off five or six feet
away from me, and he got up,
and I was lying
down with my camera.
He got up, and he started
walking towards me.
And I was a little intimidated
with this very large animal
coming.
So I stood up, and
I was about to move
and the guide behind me,
the Ugandan guy behind me
just kept whispering in my ear.
He was like don't move.
Don't move.
And the silverback went
right in front of me.
I could have reached
down and pet him.
But the whole time
that was happening,
my guide just kept saying over
and over and over, don't move.
So when you see a gorilla,
it's an amazing experience.
I strongly encourage you if
you ever go back to Africa
to do it.
From a tourism point
of view gorillas,
for instance, are the largest
grossing tourism activity
in Uganda.
So the money that they
make from gorillas
actually goes back into
the economy in a good way.
The corruption
isn't so bad there.
So the money you spend, you have
to get a gorilla permit and all
of that.
But it's a lot of money,
but it's worth it.
Giraffes.
Another favorite.
Who loves giraffes?
Yeah.
Who doesn't?
Everybody sort of takes
giraffes for granted
when they go to Africa.
But giraffe populations in
Central and Eastern Africa
have declined 40% in
the last 30 years.
Not very many people sort of
take that into consideration.
This is a reticulated giraffe
at a private conservancy,
Old Yogi in Kenya.
Giraffe populations are
in trouble in Africa.
Why?
They're poached for their
skins, occasionally meat.
Their tails are used
for fly swatters
and mostly for their
skins and meat.
Unfortunately, also, they're
running out of habitat, food,
all sorts of problems.
If you ever get a
chance to do a walking
safari with a herd of giraffes,
I highly recommend it.
When they run, it looks
like they're in slow motion.
It's one of my favorite
things to watch ever,
but a lot of people don't
realize the giraffes are
in big trouble.
All across the continent,
they're in big trouble.
Elephants.
Again, this is a herd of
elephants in Amboseli National
Park in Kenya.
Elephants are a huge driver
in the economy in Africa.
It's estimated that
one elephant can
bring in over one million
dollars of tourism
revenue in its life, versus
a few thousand dollars
for the poacher
who gets the tusk.
Poaching is an
interesting thing.
They will take the mothers--
elephant herds are
matriarchal societies,
so they're run by the ladies.
When the guys get to be
teenagers, they're booted out,
and the ladies stick together
the rest of their life.
Poachers will take any tusk
and leave the little guys
as orphans.
There is a great orphanage
in Nairobi, the William,
or the Daphne
Sheldrick orphanage.
Has anybody been there?
Yeah, it's great.
Last year, they had
some awesome news.
It's the first year
in their existence
they haven't taken
in a new orphan.
So that means poaching is
down, which is great news.
The way poaching works,
as I understand it,
there's usually one
guy in a village who
owns the gun and the bullets.
And if you want to poach
an elephant or a rhino,
you go rent the gun, buy a
few bullets, and off you go.
Mostly, you get your
friends with you.
And when you sneak
into the conservancy,
you take the gun
apart, and each person
has a different part of the gun.
You ride your motorbike in,
you put the gun together,
you find your animal, shoot it.
Gun disappears.
Boom, out you go.
That's normally how it's done.
You actually buy the
bullets, and they're not
very good shots.
And that's why,
unfortunately, in a lot
of cases when an
animal is poached,
it's a long, horrible process,
because the people aren't very
good at what they're doing.
Some of them are.
Anyway, you can see in some
places you go in Africa,
elephants are very
wary of people.
They'll sort of shy back
from you when you get close.
In other places in Africa,
where for instance, in Uganda,
where there's not so many
tourists and the poaching
isn't too bad, the elephants
are much more aggressive
towards you, and they'll
come right up to the car
and sometimes even chase
you, which can be exciting.
Any part of
conservation in Africa
must include the local people.
You can't get anywhere without
the local people on your side.
You have to give them
a reason to be invested
in the conservation program.
You have to give them
a reason to care.
You have to give them a
reason to be involved.
You can't just come in and
say, this is what we're doing.
Here we're going to do this,
this, and this, and this,
and you're going to
be happy about it.
You have to be really on
board with the local people
for any long term
conservation plan.
Unfortunately, wildlife
conservation in Africa
is not just like a 10 year
deal or a 20 year deal.
It's forever.
It's a forever deal.
If the animals are going to
survive past our lifetimes,
in your children's
lifetimes, it's
24 hours, 24/7 conservation
for the foreseeable future.
And the only way
that's sustainable
is by getting local
people on your side.
These two lovely
ladies are Samburu,
right outside the Samburu
National Park in Kenya.
And they work with
an organization
called Ewaso Lions.
It's a small
organization in Kenya,
run by a fabulous
woman, Shivani.
And what she does is she finds
women in the village, who maybe
are a little older,
maybe they're divorced,
maybe they've lost
their husbands,
their children are
away, they really
don't maybe have too much
to do, or not involved
that much in the village.
She'll take them out.
She'll teach them how to drive.
She'll teach them
how to use a radio.
how to use a GPS.
And they become lion guardians.
So they drive around,
and they look for lions.
And when they find a lion,
they report that to the village
so that they can move
the livestock out
of the way of the lion,
and it gives them purpose.
It gives them purpose
to protect the animals.
in their village.
It gives them responsibility.
It gives them skills that maybe
other villagers don't have.
So these small programs,
Wild Aid partners
with several small NGOs,
Ewaso Lions being one of them,
and they really are-- it's a
very sort of micro conservation
efforts, just in
one little area.
So not all conservation is like
WWF or something like that,
worldwide.
A lot of conservation is
just very small, little bits
here and there,
getting the job done.
But these ladies were great.
I spent all afternoon
with them and bought
some of their jewelry.
Very interesting people.
Chimps, another
of the great apes.
Most people think
chimps are doing OK.
You really don't hear
much about chimps.
The chimps are under a
lot of pressure in Africa.
This particular chimp
is part of a group
of chimps called the Bulindi
chimps in a region of Uganda
called Hoima.
This chimp is-- there's
five families of chimps
in this area of Uganda.
Uganda has about
5,000 chimps left.
But this chimp is part of
a family of about 20 to 25.
And they have been-- because
of habitat destruction,
they've been reduced to about
two acres of forested land, two
acres.
So it's about, maybe the
parking lot out here.
That's it.
That's all they have.
And the area runs-- it's not
just one nice block of forest.
It goes sort of down a stream
between everybody's yards.
So these chimps are now stranded
in an island of humanity,
and the only way they
can eat is to raid
farmer's crops is to
interact with people
is to cross busy highways, is--
basically, it's a
wild family of chimps
stranded in a sea of humanity.
There are five such
families across Uganda.
What is the cause?
Well, in traditional
African families,
the family gets a plot
of land, and then,
as they have children,
they divide that plot
of land up for their children.
And so the plots get smaller
and smaller and smaller,
and then as the children go
to school, they have to sell--
they cut the wood down
to pay for school fees,
to pay for the books, the
uniforms, blah, blah, blah.
And unfortunately,
what that does
is it creates less and less
habitat for the chimps.
The chimps get more
and more desperate.
The chimps interact more and
more with people and problems
arise.
There's a great little
foundation called The Bulindi
Chimps, B-U-L-I-N-D-I. And it's
a one guy and his girlfriend,
and he's trying to
save these chimps.
He's a great guy, if
you're looking for a place
to donate $5 for $10 for
Christmas, he's great.
And it'll help these chimps.
This chimp, when I
was photographing her,
she was picking sticks off the
tree and throwing them at me,
trying to nail me
with the sticks.
It was pretty good.
I have one of the sticks
at home in my apartment.
She was a good--
she had a good arm.
But anyway, it was a really
sad day to film some of these.
You have to have--
unfortunately, sometimes you
have to have a good sense
of humor in my work,
because you can see a lot
of not so great stories.
The great wildebeest migration.
Has anybody seen that in Africa?
Yes, it's pretty amazing, huh?
It's unbelievable.
So this was last February
in Ndutu, which is
next to Serengeti in Tanzania.
For those of you who don't
know, the wildebeest migration
is the largest
remaining overland sort
of migration of animals left.
There's a large one in Alaska,
the porcupine herd of caribou,
but this is a little bit bigger.
It's about 2 million
animals, and they
make this circular
track of 500 miles
in search of food and water.
They're zebras.
There's wildebeest.
There's antelope.
There's all kinds of animals.
And when you watch
them, you can't really
tell who's making the decisions.
But somebody is.
I mean, there'd be
a little line going
that way, another line going
that way.
The reason I show this picture
is because it's uncertain
where this migration will
end up in 30 or 40 years,
because of climate change.
Right now, most of the
area of the migration
is in protected zones
in Kenya and Tanzania.
They sort of do a big circle
between Kenya and Tanzania.
But the question
is will it shift
because of climate
change, will that
habitable zone sort
of shift around?
And if it does, what will
happen to these animals?
Will they start migrating
through Nairobi?
That would be quite a scene.
So that's another issue that
we work with at Wild Aid.
We do climate change programs,
for instance, in Asia,
to get people to
ride more bikes,
to eat less meat,
things like that.
So it's really a holistic thing.
When you look at
conservation, you
have to look at
these big problems
of climate change,
these little problems
of the villagers, everything.
Lions.
Who doesn't love lions?
I love lions.
Unfortunately, lions are
not doing well in Africa.
There are only about 20,000
lions left on the continent,
and they're being killed mostly
from human wildlife conflict.
They will attack a farmer's
livestock or something
like that, and the farmer will
retaliate and kill the lion.
This lion I shot at
sunrise in Tanzania.
It was Serengeti in Tanzania.
And she was looking at me for a
while and then got up and left.
Lions are incredible creatures.
And they need our help.
Lions could be extinct in the
wild in 10 years or 20 years.
So it's a dire situation
for a lot of lions,
and another part of the problem,
as with tigers in India,
these animals are relegated
to small conservation islands,
sort of, conservancies here
and there, all over the place.
And it's very difficult for them
to get from one to the other.
So the DNA pools are getting
smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller.
So there has to be a good way
to try to intermix these lions,
and it's becoming more
and more challenging
as more development comes
across Africa, and by the way,
the tigers in India, which
are doing really well,
have the same problem going from
one tiger reserve to the other
in India.
Local people.
Again, local people
are incredibly
important when you think
about any conservation plan.
These are some Maasai herders
in the Ngorongoro Conservation
area just on the other side of
Ngorongoro crater in Tanzania.
This is sort of the
back side of the crater,
and this sort of slopes
down to the Serengeti.
This is called a Boma.
It's their village
where they live.
And these are young cattle.
The older cattle were
off in the hills.
But this is another organization
we work with called cop
lions, which is right in the
Ngorongoro Conservation area,
and they work with
Maasai tribes to--
in some Maasai culture--
make sure I get this right--
a young man, to go from a child
to a man, he kills a lion.
Is that correct?
And so the cop lions
works with the young men,
and they train them
not to kill the lions,
but to protect the lions,
just like the women
in the previous photo.
So they go out, and
they guard the lions,
and they take pride
from not killing a lion,
but from saving a lion.
And this is very important.
Again, it's a very small
organization called cop lions.
And they only work in the
Ngorongoro crater area.
But it's working.
It's having a positive effect.
Another problem with
livestock growth
is that the villagers will push
their livestock after they've
overgrazed a certain area
outside the conservation zone.
The livestock will
get slowly pushed
inside the conservation zone,
where the vegetation is better,
where there's better food.
What that does is it pushes
the livestock closer and closer
and closer to the
lions, and then you
end up having inevitable
problems with lions
attacking sheep and cattle, and
then the villagers retaliating.
So that's an issue
where there's a lot
of smart minds around the world
trying to figure out high tech
enclosures for sheep and
cattle, for instance, how
to keep livestock safe in the
middle of nowhere from lions.
We work with
organizations that use
advanced solar power, sort
of motion detector lighting.
We work with some
villagers in Uganda,
who've cooked up this, like
for instance, elephants raiding
crops.
They've cooked up this
elephant repellent, which
is elephant dung and
chili pepper and ginger
and rotten eggs all mixed up and
then fermented for like a week.
And then they run
around, and they spray it
all over their crops.
It is the most foul
thing you've ever seen.
But the elephants hate it.
So the elephants stay away.
I mean, how you came up with
that recipe, I don't know.
I had to film it one day,
and it was like not easy.
Not easy.
Anyway, those are situations
where simple ideas like this
can go a long way.
So if you're bored
at home thinking
how would I keep a
lion away from a sheep,
or how would I keep an
elephant out of the crops,
you know, just any idea--
there's organizations
all across Africa
trying basically anything
that works to try
to mitigate this problem.
Yes, it's a lovely
photo of zebras,
but that's not why
I'm showing it to you,
and it's a lovely
Egyptian duck here,
for you birders out there.
This was shot in a private
conservancy, Old Yogi,
in Kenya.
It's a beautiful,
beautiful place.
It's Tom Hanks'
favorite vacation place.
It's a very expensive
place to go.
If you rent the
whole place, you're
guaranteed to have
6,000 acres on your own.
But anyway, they let us
come and shoot one day.
And I was lucky enough to have
these zebras line up like this.
The reason I'm showing you this
picture is because of water.
Water is a huge
issue everywhere.
Here, water is a big
problem, but in Africa, it's
a large problem as well.
There's wells being
drilled all the way--
it's kind of like the
Central Valley here.
They're depleting the water much
faster than it is replenished.
And that's another thing that
great minds could focus on
is how we keep
water coming fresh
and on a daily basis for all
these people that need it.
A lot of animals have to travel
long distances to find water,
and then they end up competing
with the livestock and all
that sort of stuff.
So it's an issue.
Another big problem in
Africa is deforestation.
The continent of Africa
is being deforested
at about twice the rate
of the rest of the planet.
Why?
This.
Charcoal.
If you drive around rural
Africa, at least parts
of Africa that I've
been to, you'll
pass hundreds of
these bags of charcoal
on the side of the road.
And people buy them,
like for instance,
truckers when they've gone
out into the countryside,
deliver their load on the
way back into the city.
They'll buy a bunch of charcoal
and fill up their truck
and truck that into the city.
This is in the port of
Zanzibar in Tanzania.
These guys are unloading
sacks of charcoal
from traditional dhow sailing
ships in the port of Zanzibar,
which has changed very
little in about 900 years.
So this is what it would have
looked like even 500 years ago.
Somebody told me that just
alone on the island of Zanzibar,
20,000 sacks of
charcoal a day are used.
Now, why people won't use
natural gas or propane?
There's a lot of NGOs that
have tried to introduce
those kind of stoves.
It's because it's a very sort
of ingrained cultural practice.
For instance, in
Uganda the local people
believe that in order for
your beans to taste right,
you have to slow cook them
for four hours over charcoal.
You can't hot cook them over 20
minutes in a propane pressure
cooker.
So it's a very
difficult process.
It's very-- oh thank you--
changing these cultural beliefs.
But unfortunately
Africa, like I said,
is being deforested
at a huge rate.
And sooner or later,
like everything else,
we're going to run out of wood.
If you drive around
Africa, you see it.
It's all over the place.
For instance, if you go
trek with the chimpanzees
or the gorillas in the
Bwindi Impenetrable Forest,
as you walk to the
edge of the forest,
it's nothing but deforested
hillsides, and then
all of a sudden, where
the national park starts,
it's a shear wall
of forest canopy.
Bushmeat is another
major problem in Africa.
Bushmeat is any animal
that is consumed
for either food
or economic gain.
Mostly, they are
animals like this.
This is a hartebeest in
Murchison Falls National
Park in Uganda.
Mostly they're antelopes
that are hunted for meat.
For instance, on the way to
the park, on the day before,
there was a guy
walking down the road
with the hind quarter of one
of these animals over his leg,
over his shoulder.
It's illegal to
hunt these animals,
but they're a huge source of
protein for people and money.
They're sold to restaurants
locally and exported abroad.
Unfortunately, the only way
to get a lot of bushmeat
is to go into the
conservation area,
the national parks, set
traps, harvest the bushmeat.
But as you'll see
soon, those traps
do devastating damage
to other animals.
Gorillas, again.
This was a gorilla I
shot the first time
I trekked with gorillas.
I've done it twice.
This gorilla and I were both
enjoying a torrential rain
storm.
As you can see,
she's very happy.
The great thing
about gorillas is
if you spend enough
time with them,
or actually a lot of
animals in Africa,
and this is
something I encourage
you to do if you go back
to Africa, spend time
with these animals.
A lot of time.
A lot of safaris, they
pull up, they see a lion,
they're like, oh look lion
[MIMICS PHOTOS BEING TAKEN]
and off you go.
You don't really learn
anything about a lion.
You get a picture, selfie.
But that's about it.
I strongly encourage you
if you go back to Africa
or if you haven't been to
Africa, when you go on safari,
ask your driver when you find an
animal that you're really into
or really like,
just sit and wait.
Other Jeeps will come and
leave and come and leave.
But then sooner or later,
you'll find yourself alone
with that animal, and you
will see unbelievable things.
If you just sit
still, you will see
animals are so much like us,
and there's so many things
that they do, which
are entertaining,
far more than your
house cat or your dog.
Believe me, a 400 pound
gorilla is way more
entertaining than your cat.
So I just encourage
you as a person,
if you're a photographer,
or you're into nature,
just sit with the
animal, just sit.
Tourism.
Like I said earlier, gorillas
are the biggest source
of tourism income in Uganda.
Tourism is a double-edged sword.
It brings in badly
needed economic revenue,
but on the other
hand, the effects
it has on the national
parks and the animals
is not really settled.
For instance, this photograph
I shot in a place--
in a national park called
Lake Mburu in Uganda.
It's a beautiful
little national park.
Normally, when I
travel in Africa,
I have an armed
national park ranger
with me almost all the time.
These people had rented their
own car, which you can do,
and they had driven it off road.
As you can see, she's
very excited about getting
her iPhone photo of something.
And the problem is when they
drive off road, a lot of times,
tourists don't
respect the wildlife.
They get way too close.
They speed down the road.
They kill animals on the road.
So if you go to Africa, if you
choose this mode of safari,
do it responsibly.
Or if you go to Africa and do
any safari, do it responsibly.
Make sure that they're not--
if you get an off road permit--
you can get them.
They're difficult to get.
But you can get an
off road permit, which
allows you to drive anywhere.
Don't be these guys.
Do it right.
Respect the area that you're in.
You wouldn't want
people over here
driving through your front
yard to look at your dog.
Again, tourism is a
double-edged sword.
Sometimes, when
you go to Africa,
you'll be blessed to have the
experience all to yourself,
but more than likely,
this is what you'll see.
This is in Ngorongoro
National Park in Tanzania,
one of the most amazing--
it's kind of the
Disneyland of Africa.
Tanzania has, I
think, if I'm right,
the densest population of
animals anywhere in Africa.
So if you go on safari,
Tanzania is a good place to go.
Unfortunately, in the
Ngorongoro Crater area, itself--
it's not that large, it's
large, but not huge--
on any given day, there can be
about 300 Jeeps in the crater.
So just trying to get a
perfect shot of an animal
can be very difficult.
And a lot of times,
you'll find a lion or
something like this,
and the Jeeps will
just follow the lion.
There are rules
about how long you're
supposed to spend with an animal
and all that sort of stuff.
But a lot of times,
they're not followed.
So again, nobody's really
sort of done any studies
that I'm aware of the effect on
animals, except that sometimes,
for instance, when
you follow a kill,
if you're tracking
a cheetah or a lion
in Africa, trying to
photograph the kill,
and you interrupt
that kill by putting
your car in the wrong place,
the animal will stop the kill
and move on and perhaps
miss a badly needed meal.
Again, here's a sample photo.
For those of you
who've been on safari,
you've probably seen this.
This is inside the
crater, Ngorongoro Crater,
and inside here
somewhere is an animal.
As a filmmaker, I've
been doing, like I said,
wildlife films for a long time.
When I see this, I just tell my
driver, let's just keep going.
We'll find something else.
And the amazing thing is if
you're super into photography,
and you want to get some amazing
shots of animals in Africa,
you got to go out really
early before everyone else
and stay late.
And the minute you
find an animal,
get your Jeep in the right
place and start taking pictures,
because you've only got 5 or
10 minutes before the guy gets
on his radio and says, hey,
we've got a great lion here.
So unfortunately, like I
said, the money from tourism
is a badly needed resource,
but nobody's really
quite sure of the
long term effects,
and tourism is just growing and
growing and growing and growing
and growing.
Another big problem
in Africa people
aren't aware of too
much is vultures.
I bet you didn't know vultures,
some species of vultures
have declined by 90% in
three generations in Africa.
90%.
Vultures are now a
threatened species.
Why is that?
Who wants to kill a vulture?
Nobody wants to kill a vulture.
The problem is when
a lion kills a sheep,
the farmer gets mad at the lion.
He knows the lion will come
back to eat that sheep.
So he poisons the
sheep to kill the lion,
but who eats the
sheep before the lion?
The vulture.
Vultures are dying at a rate,
mostly due to poisoning.
And this is another side effect
of human wildlife conflict.
This is why so much energy is
being put into Africa right now
to mitigate human wildlife
conflict, because of species
like vultures, who are dying as
innocent bystanders, basically.
So you'll think twice now the
next time you see a vulture.
And the vultures
here, they had just--
this is a dead wildebeest
in Serengeti in Tanzania.
It's amazing to watch
them fight over it
and fight with each other.
I sat and watched these
guys for about 45 minutes
before my driver got-- he
was like, what are you doing?
Nobody watches vultures
for 45 minutes.
He's like, let's
go look at lions.
I'm like, no, we're
going to stay right here.
Leopards.
Another favorite animal.
Did everybody see a leopard
when they went to Africa?
Yeah, good.
Good, good, good.
Leopards are hard to see.
They're very elusive.
They're very shy creatures.
The best way I look
for a Leopard is they
like to sit in trees like this
is look for the tail dangling
down there below the branch.
If you look far away from
it, you'll see a tree,
you won't be able
to see the leopard,
but you'll be able
to see the tail.
That's the way I
try to spot them.
There are only about 12,000
leopards left in the wild.
They're hunted mainly for
their skins, their skulls,
their bones, their teeth.
It's unfortunate, but leopards
are a prized animal still
to this day.
Occasionally, they're
even trapped and sold
to wealthy families
in the Middle East
as pets, along with cheetahs.
But if you're lucky enough--
this was in the
Serengeti or Ndutu
near in Tanzania,
about 6:30 at night.
That's when you best
see a leopard is
very early in the morning
or very late at night.
Unfortunately, like
I said, leopards
are prized for their
skins and bones.
Another big problem
in Africa, which
we have here in San
Francisco, is development.
Where do we put all the people?
This is a big problem
in Africa as well.
Cities are growing rapidly.
The population is
growing rapidly.
The wealth is growing rapidly.
People want nice places to live.
They want nice cities.
This is Nairobi in Kenya.
This area in the foreground
is Nairobi National Park.
It's a small national park
just outside of Nairobi,
where you can go just for
the day and see some animals.
Unfortunately, if you go
to Nairobi National Park
and drive around
for the day, you'll
see that the animals aren't
in really great condition.
They're under a lot of
pressure from the city.
In fact, if you
spend a day there,
you'll see people driving their
car, flying down the road,
and there's lions right
on the side of the road.
So it's sort of an endemic--
it's a good little
microcosm to see
what's happening with
development all over Africa.
This is sort of a sad
moment in our journey here.
This is Sudan.
This was the last
Northern White male rhino
left on the planet, who
died earlier this year.
I had the chance
to visit him twice
over the last three years.
He was 45 when he died.
A normal rhino lives to be
about 30 something 36, 37 maybe.
If you ever get a
chance to pet a rhino,
they love to be scratched
right behind their ear
there and right under their leg
here, sort of their underarm.
Rhinos are actually
very gentle creatures.
You have to be
careful around them.
They weigh a lot.
If you're standing next to
a rhino and the rhino moves,
you kind of got to move with it.
But they're incredibly wonderful
creatures, and even this rhino,
at this advanced age,
the only one of his kind,
they sawed his horns down
to make him less attractive
for poachers.
He was in a walled enclosure
under 24 hour a day
armed guard his entire
life, because of his horns.
Unfortunately, he was
not able to breed,
and the two females that are
left are too old to breed.
They did take a lot
of samples from him,
and there are some organizations
here in the United States
and in Germany working
to clone rhinos.
I don't know-- there's
no news about that yet,
but I know that there are
two organizations working
to clone this species of rhino.
But I think if you
look at this photo,
you'll see a wonderful
creature and be reminded
that extinction is forever.
Once these animals are
gone, they're gone.
They're not coming
back, and that
is a big problem
in Africa, and it's
a big problem you could
see in your lifetime,
your children could
see in your lifetime.
No more lions, no more
rhinos, no more giraffes.
Can you imagine taking
your child to Africa
and not being able
to see a lion?
I mean, that's Africa, a lion.
So think about
that for a minute.
This is what I was talking
earlier about bushmeat trade.
These are the
snares that are set.
This is one ranger
facility in one corner
of a national park in Uganda.
This is the amount
of snares they
collected in just six months.
These are all made out
of just thick wire.
They're set like a
noose in the bush,
and as the animal steps into
it, it tightens around there,
and then one end is attached to
a tree, and they can't get out.
And then the hunters come
by and kill the animal.
Unfortunately, this snare
doesn't care what it catches.
So say you're out to
catch a hartebeest, which
is a large antelope creature,
and you want to eat that.
Well, you might end up
with a cape buffalo.
You might end up with a lion.
You might end up
with an elephant.
Another problem in
Africa with bushmeat
is homemade spring traps,
you know, the big kind
of old bear, Alaska bear traps.
They are placed all
over the bush as well,
and they harm not only
the wildlife, but rangers
as well on patrol have to
be very careful of stepping
into these large traps.
They'll pull you--
as you can see here,
severed the foot right
off of an antelope.
And here is a pile
of range of us snaps,
snap traps in the
same ranger station.
This is about a six
month supply of traps
in one ranger station in one
corner of one national park.
So you can see that
made out of leaf springs
for cars, all sorts of things.
So this is the point
of showing you these.
It's how we get people
weaned off of bushmeat.
It's economic issues.
It's food issues.
It's cultural issues.
It's all sorts of things.
But we need to get
people convinced
that these animals are worth far
more alive than they are dead.
That's the trick.
Here's what happens when
an animal gets in a snare.
Here's an elephant
with a normal trunk.
Here's an elephant missing
his trunk because it
got chopped off in a snare.
The morning I filmed
these guys in Uganda,
there were four young bull
elephants, male elephants,
and three of the four
had damaged trunks
from snares, three of the four.
This was the only
one who was normal.
This is a lion caught
in a snare from Uganda.
The snare has
actually been cut off.
They tranquilized the lion
and put on a GPS collar,
but this is the scar
left over from the snare.
So you can see that these
are incredibly damaging
simple things.
It's just a wire in the bush.
But obviously, the people
don't want to catch lions.
They're not trying to eat lions.
They wanted to catch
some sort of antelope.
Another problem with bushmeat,
this is a cape buffalo.
So you have guys running around
with spears and bow and arrow
and basically any weapon
they can come up with.
This was in Uganda as well.
I'm not sure whether this animal
was the target of the attack
or whether he
charged the hunters,
and the hunters threw a
spear in self-defense.
I'm not sure.
But at any rate, that
spear is not coming out,
and that animal is going
to live with that spear
for the rest of its life.
So these are the
sort of problems
that you don't see
when you're on safari,
or maybe you will see
an animal with a spear,
but there's not a whole
lot of questions there.
Ivory, again, is
a major problem.
This is a habituated sort of
socialized bull elephant in Old
Yogi Conservancy in Kenya.
He's 12 feet tall.
So when I was taking this
photo, I was about this close
to that elephant, hoping
that he wasn't going to move.
Elephants, again, are an
iconic species in Africa,
and we need to work very
hard to curb the ivory trade
and make sure that, you know,
that anything ivory related
doesn't belong on you.
It belongs on the elephant.
This is a good example of
how ivory fuels conflict
across Africa.
The wildlife trade
conservatively
is estimated to be about
$20 billion worldwide,
the trade in illegal parts.
For instance, Boko
Haram in Nigeria
has been well funded
through their trade
of ivory of Nigerian elephants.
This is in a ranger
station in Uganda as well.
This markings on the ivory here
is dried blood and some AK 47s.
So you can see that there's
all sorts of sizes of ivory.
And again, they'll take
any size or whatever.
But ivory, not only--
it's like drug running
in South America.
It fuels violence, and it fuels
instability in these countries.
Again, this is that same bull
elephant in Old Yogi in Kenya.
I just love this guy, and it's
a great photo of the ivory.
You can see how in the
natural environment, how ivory
gets chucked up quite a bit.
Here's an animal.
Does anybody know what this is?
Pangolin.
Pangolin is the most
trafficked animal
on the planet, the most
illegally trafficked animal
on the planet.
It's the anteater family.
These little guys,
when they're afraid,
they roll up in
a ball like that.
It's about like this big.
If you were to hold them
by the tail and unwrap it,
it would be about that long.
But their meat is
considered a delicacy
in many Asian countries,
and their scales
are dried and ground up
and considered medicinal,
have special
medicinal properties,
none of which have
ever been proved.
These three pangolins
are the only pangolins
I have ever seen alive.
They're very elusive animals.
Nocturnal creatures.
You can go all day in
Africa, I mean, for a year
and never see a pangolin.
Have you seen one?
Yeah.
Yeah, they're very hard to see.
I've looked and tried and
tried and tried and tried.
This was in a bushmeat
market in Yaounde, Cameroon,
which is the capital
city of Cameroon.
Here's the lady who
was selling them.
That's her foot.
You can get an idea
of how big they are.
She was selling each one of
these pangolins for $10 each.
I offered to pay her
$10 to take the photo.
I took this photo
with my iPhone,
because I was there
pretending just
to be a tourist with
my Cameroonian guide.
As soon as I gave
her the $10, all hell
broke loose in the bushmeat
market, and we left.
So I was able to get one
photo of these poor pangolins
in a very sad state.
There were about 20 pangolins
in this bushmeat market,
all in various stages
of consciousness.
That is one activity I
highly discourage you
from doing if you're
ever in Africa
is to visit a bushmeat market.
It might sound
fun, but it's not.
Anyway, pangolins,
do some research.
If you don't know much about
pangolins, do some research.
The BBC just came out with a
really funny little pangolin
movie about three or four
months ago about a woman
in Zimbabwe, I think, who
runs a pangolin orphanage.
It's a really cute movie.
Unfortunately, this is the
result of the leopard trade.
Here you can see the
leopard skin and the teeth.
This is in a ranger
station in Uganda.
This is the largest
stockpile of ivory
left in the world in
Dar Es Salaam, Tanzania.
It's about 50 metric ton
or 80 metric tons of ivory,
worth about $50 million
on the open market.
This is one shelf inside
of two gigantic warehouses.
The good news and the bad news.
About a year ago, Kenya
had a similar stockpile,
and they burnt it.
They made a big
deal of burning it.
There are a lot
of organizations,
Wild Aid included,
pressuring Tanzania
to get rid of this ivory.
One of the suggestions
we've given them
is to grind it up
and create a monument
to elephants out of it,
and they're considering it.
I met with the Tanzanian
tourism minister
when I was over
there this spring.
And he gave us a little tour
of the ivory stockpile here.
It's kind of sad to see.
But the reason they don't
get rid of this ivory
is because it's like
money in the bank.
It's like gold in the bank,
because it's still worth
quite a bit of money.
OK, we're winding down here.
This is just a
quick shot of ivory,
and hippo teeth are
also a big traded item.
You can see that this
tusk is four kilos, which
is about eight pounds, a little
bit more than eight pounds.
And I show you this,
because 100 years ago,
tusks weighing 180
pounds were not unusual,
like taller than me.
Nowadays, tusks weighing eight
pounds are what they trade,
and those are from
young, young elephants.
Sadly, here's the result
of a poached elephant.
This is what happens
to an elephant
when they take the ivory.
This is in Uganda,
in a field in Uganda.
But there is hope.
Rhinos are making a comeback
in some parts of Africa.
This is at a
conservancy in Uganda,
where rhinos were extinct in the
'80s from Idi Amin's soldiers,
driving around and
shooting wildlife,
getting drunk and
shooting wildlife.
There is a conservancy in Uganda
called Ziwa Rhino Conservancy.
They started with six,
and now they have 24.
Brenda and I were lucky
one day to see all 24.
This is a one-month-old baby.
So there are organizations
working very hard
to bring these animals back,
but each one of these rhinos
has an armed guard 24 hours a
day, every single one of them.
So it's a very
expensive proposition.
There are other countries in
Africa doing good conservation
work.
Botswana is doing well.
And there are other
countries in Africa.
They're really pushing
hard for conservation.
So again, people
in Africa, this is
a young girl from the
Ngorongoro Maasai tribe.
The population in Africa
currently is 1.3 billion,
but it's projected to
double in the next 30 years.
So a lot of minds
need to get together
to figure out where all
the food comes from,
the water comes from,
the land comes from.
There are challenges
ahead for sure.
But this was a beautiful village
I visited in the Ngorongoro
conservation area.
Lions, again, what's
the history, or what's
the future for lions?
This is the same lion I
photographed earlier you saw.
This is after she got
sick of me and just showed
me the back of her head.
And elephants.
This elephant is
in the Nile River
in Murchison Park in Uganda.
The ivory trade is coming down.
Wild Aid recently got Sotheby's
and another big auction house
to no longer sell
animal products,
like rhino horn,
things like that.
So little incremental steps.
But that's what we have to
do, just keep the pressure on.
And these are some elephants
in Tarangire National
Park in Tanzania.
It's a great place
to see elephants.
If you ever go there,
and you want to see just
see elephants,
Tarangire National Park.
So that's it.
That's me.
Here's my website.
Here's Wild Aid's website.
You can write me an email
if you have any questions.
I strongly encourage you to
find a way to get involved.
Visit Wild Aid's website.
Visit some of the other
organizations I talked about.
The next time you
go back to Africa,
find a way to do eco-friendly
safaris or safaris that
give back to the community,
things like that.
And I'm happy to
take any questions
if there's any questions.
I know we're just
about out of time.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In terms of
conservation efforts,
which African
country would you say
is leading the efforts, like
the government actually doing
a good job?
ANDY WEGST: I'm not
that well versed
on the politics of all that.
I know that each country has
its own unique challenges.
Some countries are doing
better than others.
For instance, Tanzania
really recognizes the value
of tourism, as does Kenya.
Uganda is coming up.
They see it.
But it's very difficult to get
that sort of infrastructure
in place, the
hotels, the airports,
all that sort of stuff.
A lot of countries see
that tourism is a future,
and their wildlife is important.
But the problem
is they need help
sort of generating that
foundation, where tourists will
come, because you
need the hotels,
you need the airports you
need all that sort of stuff.
So there are a lot of countries
sort of moving that direction.
And when you travel
through Africa, I mean,
it's obvious when you visited
a country like Cameroon, which
basically has next to zero
tourist infrastructure,
and then you go to a
country like Kenya,
where you can stay in beautiful
hotels and restaurants,
and so--
it's a varied picture
across the continent.
Some countries do
better than others.
But it's just a matter of
trying to pull everybody along.
And unfortunately, corruption
is a big part of it.
So it's a challenge for sure.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering, do
you have any recommendations
for finding some of these
eco-friendly safaris,
or how to--
ANDY WEGST: I can't give you
the name of any specific safari,
but if you're interested
in traveling to Africa,
there are some companies
that do better than others.
There are some
companies that give
a certain percentage of profits
back into the local community.
There are companies-- there are
lodge companies, for instance,
in Tanzania that only hire local
people to work at the lodges.
There are-- so I would just do a
little research when you travel
and make sure you're going with
a company that gives something
back, that involves a
community that provides--
they're not bringing in their
workers from somewhere else.
They're employing local people
and all that kind of stuff.
Thank you very much for
attending, and I appreciate it.